i don't need a hammer
okay
all right we started out uh so we're
doing insurance
first right we're no insurance here
all right so who do we have we have hunt
yeah who else is on insurance
[Laughter]
john's got the list
okay
uh
sounds pretty good
okay
and who's who was your other dems
there she is okay
okay so everybody's here right yeah all
right
uh
okay uh who i entertain a motion of any
expedient to legislate uh which one are
you doing but we're doing
it mila's
multiple employer welfare arrangements
the one that evidently
the senator no one no one told her
i'm sure the department did tell her but
she just didn't
didn't hear it
okay
ito okay representative bartlett second
by him saint representative hunt
protest we'll just be two sec
okay uh
an expedient to legislate any discussion
on the motion
anybody need to know want more
well there is this perception out there
that we could
um create a limited market in the market
for people to have can come together to
create health insurance i mean i hear a
lot of times people keep talking the
chamber of commerce's canada chamber of
commerce you know so and it's just that
the people don't
need to know that that's just never
going to work
uh for insurance you know you need you
need critical mass
yeah you got to get you got to really
make it you to to handle
that uh the statistical odds of having a
cancer patient that's going to cost you
a million dollars you need to have 3 000
lives
and
that's really where that's our meewal
law is the 3000. we have on the books
this other do we what is it called the
other one that's called
yeah once you just
have them
the purchasing alliance that's it that's
right purchasing alliance
and we've had in the person you want to
hit the mic the purchasing alliance is
on the books
that's correct and one of the
requirements would be to be a qualified
purchasing alliance and uh you're
correct that had been in 3 000 numbers
for a long time last year as a part of
legislative i think was last year as a
part of legislation has changed to 500
to 500. you're right i mean to the
extent that you're looking at sort of a
critical mass and some predictability
higher numbers help right yeah so you
got to have it and then but there's the
startup cost to put one of these things
together so an idea of a pilot program
uh you know where that ever came from i
don't know but but you're just you're
not gonna you don't you don't you're not
gonna go into it with knowing that it
could sunset in two years on you i mean
if you're gonna go into something like
that you would you would it's a serious
investment to make it pull it off
wouldn't you agree
yes
perfect answer
okay any discussion on the motion of any
speed to legislate okay committee please
say ah
right raise your hand
one two three four five six
uh seven all those opposed all right
perfect
yes please
the clerk would love it if you do the
blurb ahead of time
not this card the house clerk
we're going to execute this on next
wednesday
yeah so this afternoon
so yeah just no no next wednesday we're
going to exit second next we're going to
exactly next wednesday okay
all right uh
relative to coverage for certain mental
illnesses
why am i drawing a blank on this bill
uh
when did we hear this bill
tyler can you help us out
yeah so senate bill 373 was actually one
requested by the insurance department in
order to basically take advantage of
federal guidance around mental health
parity comparative analysis and
requirements that are being imposed by
the federal government through the dol
on carriers serving self-insured
employers the insurance department has
been working on mental health parity
compliance for a long time and to the
extent we align our efforts with the
federal efforts then we're asking the
carriers to produce one set of
comparative analysis
taking advantage of the economies of
scale with that okay so i think we have
an amendment for this one is that yes
that's why it's here
that's why it's on the calendar okay
uh john yep the amendment was in the
last part it was supposed to read the
commissioner shall adopt rules as
necessary right very simple little
amendment
kristen do we do we get an amendment
made up for that one three
okay
ouch all right
[Laughter]
uh
shoot okay
all right so yeah because it was going
to be
the commission
[Music]
shall adopt rules if necessary
it's fine with us as necessary
as necessary
okay
do you mind just sending that to her and
so that we can
have that
for the exact session
yes
whether yeah the channel is not being
deleted so the challenge is going to go
back
i'm
and the senate changed it to may
because all they did was change that one
word and we're changing it is
adopted as necessary
which is same as his shot there's two
ways to say shall we
okay
all right so you'll get you'll send that
over to her we can do that okay so we
can't really
i mean i guess i can take a straw vote
is everybody okay with that amendment
with this bill yeah okay let's draw a
vote okay
i mean i don't think it's enough to
to vote in in an opposition but it just
seems like a wonky way of doing language
what's the better way to say it
tyler i think we're flexible i think
either way to the extent that look i
think at the end of the day if rules are
necessary we will do them we just don't
want to be obligated and this really
came out of an lba audit of the
department you didn't do rules when it
says you shall do rules so anyway you
get to a point where we have some
flexibility we're happy
so who who thought this was necessary
i'm trying to remember
who what english teacher thought we
should change in the first place
maybe you did client i may i'm no i i
didn't propose it that's for sure but
i know i have my notes here but i don't
know does anybody remember
i did make a note to follow up on it i
don't remember but i remember the
conversation i remember the conversation
but
and as i said i i'm i'm willing to
support the boat in either either
direction
okay i just the wording and i think we
started to see that wording elsewhere i
think
uh some other bill we had that on or we
suggested that himself i have to admit i
like the word may
because implies that they have to think
about it
i must admit i like me better than chal
i think that's one of my rules of thumb
if we stay with me when it comes to
health insurance and mandates
it does it doesn't matter either way
we we initially get drafted with may but
we're flexible
all right
paula paula former insurance
commissioner what would you rather see
okay
all right so let's just pass this as is
and then we won't have to worry about it
what do you guys think
okay
all right representative van gaal now
he's on something
okay
all right
then that would add the necessary if we
pass it as it is not in there
yeah because it's that just that's me
that's what it may mean
maybe as necessary that's what i think
the conversation came out was we wanted
to be very specific that
so
if it's may
we're giving the discretion and the
decision-making authority to them if
it's shell
then we're saying you you need to do
this no so we're not going to show you
as necessary well i thought the next
they would have to decide that it was
necessary not us so where did dean go
so deem is gone adopt rules is deemed
necessary so where are we now we're
we're done just leave it leave this just
to pass something we're not doing
anything
so what you suggested yesterday is
vanished we're just doing maybe
we're happy with it the way it is as it
is
so everything in between is off the
board now ols is a swap
yes well we did our due diligence and
we're trying to help all of us out
sure they'll appreciate that
okay
all right
so uh
is that straw still waiting
no this will forget about the straw
goddess there is a plastic straw or
paper yes
i'm sure what line is that on his tail
okay all right so
no i know as we like to carry this bill
forward who cares about mental illness
who cares about it
okay okay so but for the committee right
now we'll just i'll do it and then two
sec is a ghost monster so he can do it
okay so i will move it and
representative bartlett
seconds it uh we move ought to pass
any discussion on the motion seeing none
everyone who's in favor please raise
their hands on the subcommittee
and that's unanimous nothing okay
even better
all right
next up uh relative to financial
expectation of vulnerable adults
all right
okay so what representative bartlett
second by representative hunt
moves out to pass that right yes
okay
you want to speak to your emotion
sure
um and i think that the um all the
parties came together on this one we got
the bankers association we've got
um
merrimack county savings was also
spoke in favor
um
banking department took no position
they were okay with the language they
worked with the bankers association to
draft the bill so it looks like all the
parties involved um on this well this is
a banking bill let's try the business
that's correct
so who's on that subcommittee
so we have
weston
and let's see chris you need to go for
chris herbert
okay
right and i know you're an entry line
business because
i want insurance i thought i was only on
one okay
i know you're on insurance so all right
so at this point who have i circled
already terry you're already on you're
on now whether you like it or not now
you're on this now for the moment okay
because i've already circled your name
okay who's on first john john i think
i'm on this one i'm a utilitarian i know
you are rich
okay
i'm playing second now instead of first
three four five six
uh this is your government at work
and we'll put johnson on okay so i have
hunt patoosek johnson terry bartlett
abel and wesson the pending motion is
ought to pass all those in favor please
raise your
hand one two three
four five six seven all right
okay
uh relative to the sale of manufactured
housing parks
all right
this is just a straight out to pass
right
anybody have a problem with that
or who would like to this is number 210
all right what subcommittee is this now
mr chair
this is business
okay so i'm back home so you can be
honest i'm still on that too
now i'm on this one
oh my pen died
okay
yes
thank you mr chairman
in reading the the text of this bill i
don't see anything that provides the
residence
of a park
protection against any retribution
should they vote the wrong way yes
those who might be in opposition to
uh any uh owner organization homeowners
organization
uh but they're not gonna move we already
see where they can be charged 25
additional rent over the member lot rent
uh but how do we protect them against
any retribution because they the board
felt like they should have voted the the
other way
because that never happens i know
yeah it's like the devil's in the
details on that one
what are you talking about for
retribution i mean how how detailed
exactly yeah what kind of retrospective
do you want to do how do you how do you
charge retribution you know
it could i don't i don't know people get
pressured uh
suddenly
uh they're being noited to death on
quote-unquote violations of the rules
and
they
get uh i don't know how look if there's
a jerk in the room that person will
always manage to be at the top of the
pyramid and so and sorry not you
excluded of course um representative
greeson i think that discussion really
came up in the other bill um sb 324
this is so did you want to did you want
to bring this up with respect to this
bill because you i have retribution
with uh i agree with representative
wesley you you brought this
concern with respect to
what was it three
324 did you want
did you want to mirror that concern in
this bill as well uh
no we could certainly are we on the
mental health bill again no
sure
i will i will withdraw my comments and
concerns about uh until we get to three
times until we get to the next one and
then i'm going to lay it all out on the
line
sorry about that i did have the wrong
bill i'll remind you when we get to 324
thank you my fellow jamaicans
who's made the motion on this one who
would like to
okay restaurant western i have a i wrote
down amendment question mark is anyone
else
remembering that okay
i thought we were okay okay
okay weston second by patusek uh moves
uh ought to pass
any discussion on the motion
all right oh yes rich
uh
my reservation on on this is the special
status that the
um
let's see what is it it's the
i'm losing i'm losing this wait a second
um
the lending uh that the lending uh
organization has uh
and and the new
and the manufactured housing association
um because
it's it's it's requiring that they be
the ones who do this and
what if the association
wants to have a different organization
do it
i don't think it borrows from another
organization doing it it's large
notification
okay just notification of them but it's
it's out there but it turns out i'll
vote for this but i still don't like the
basic bill at all
so
you want to be you want to speak to that
why i mean why are you
because i think that this bill basically
these two bills basically
are ensuring that the that there's one
lender who continuously gets to be
the lender
and uh and
uh that the only one that's really
making any money from this is uh is the
previous owner
well
uh
that's not free enterprise i i mean and
if
so i i mean i just think i just think
this is a self uh
self
gratifying kind of thing in that it's
not uh it's not fair to the residents
because they're forced to they're forced
to do something
that they hadn't even signed up for
so
um
i i just i just don't like to have a
lending institution be able to do
10-year loans and automatic and and
automatically charge them again and
again and again
there's no way that that the owners can
now ever pay off the loan
because they're not charging enough to
do it and it's just ensuring it's just
ensuring
uh it's just ensuring
that
the the
lender is
perpetually going to have a loan
and perpetually will be
will be paying it off would you buy a
house this way
notifications yeah so let me cut to the
chase rich okay
this whole law was created by the
legislature in sympathy
of
mobile home park owners
who and i will just state it again
because i just want to rub it in who
refused to get a lease and have a
contract with the park owner to ensure
that they knew how much their rent
increases would be
but they never did that never have
always thought there was a reason for
them not doing it and then they came to
the legislature and say oh my god help
us out to get financing so that we can
buy the park
that was the idea the legislature
fortunately at the time because we
didn't have a we don't have a state bank
we actually have a housing authority
which is a non-profit
501 c 3 because i think i write checks
out to them okay and they
are willing to take on a loan with
how much down payment do they you
actually get you don't get any down
payment so i don't know any real estate
transaction where you can buy something
without having a down payment
that's the reason why this organization
is the
organization of choice because it's the
only one
and they're a non-profit uh and they're
all that when the money comes in they
turn it around and loan it out to other
uh people who are are struggling to be
able to get mortgages so it's a very
valuable honorable organization
and
so i know that you're feeling a little
sketchy about it but i can assure you
that they are a very good very important
part of new hampshire and it's a good
reason why we don't have a state bank
because it does what the
the south dakota state bank does which
is is to go give low financing low
mortgages in this case a mortgage that
has no down payment so yes it's a little
awkward in terms of how they do the
deals and how it's set up
but that's so it could work
thanks i hope that helps
well i don't i don't change my mind on
this but
i will go along with you
that's it
all right any more discussion on the
motion of ought to pass on senate bill
210 uh seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand
okay pass the 7-zip
and i'm sure
you'll take care of this in caucus
okay
uh senate bill 212 relative to liquor
manufacturers
do that that title needs to be changed
isn't it beverage manufacturers now
[Music]
now we're on to liquor subcommittee yes
we're now on the liquor store okay and
that would be
polio then hounton
i've got batuchik
abramson
and that greason
um subbed for abramson when necessary
okay does that sound right okay
and
who else was who are the dems
um
bolio and van hauten
get bullios here great yep
and manhattan
okay
and
[Music]
so i got patoozic reason i'll put myself
on there
so that's uh three to two
okay um
i'm gonna do this is
212 right
but no negative right
which one which one is this one
why does it change the beverage
all right
i didn't write anything on this one
okay this is just still liquor
manufacturers okay okay you don't know i
don't know
i have nothing
did i just
okay so this one is
this one
[Music]
this is the one that's okay right
you're okay with both of them right
that's right now i remember
um
yes
yeah
right
and they're going to get and they can
get a mix mixer with it
they've always been able to mix
okay
but yeah but and and and you you did
lower they on the senate side they
lowered down how much alcohol
ounce in half right
a shot
okay
all right uh
representative patusek uh seconded by
representative
billio moves out to pass
yep
go ahead
thank you mr chair
i had a question about the number 839
leader cases
something
some other bill that we have dealt with
i recall having a different number
uh and i want to make sure that we're
that we're not confusing or
contradicting or conflicting with other
bills that have passed why don't you
take a seat here
yeah
and
press the button and pull the mic and
you're good to go
so far so good okay so the question is
is this number consistent with other
farmers market legislation for instance
excuse me uh mr chairman uh
representative your committee saw a bill
earlier this year that dealt with
establishing a
liquor manufacturer license for farms
and uh that was amended
and it came back to you as a
with an amendment that
did not single out farms for the
eligibility but it singled out anybody
who wanted to get that type of license
um who manufactures under a thousand
cases
and gave them a new fee
of three hundred dollars
for that level of production if they
exceed that level of production
then their fee would go up to 16.95
which is what it is now
this this bill has to do with
it's a it's an extension if you will
of
what a liquor manufacturer can do so
let's assume that this new business gets
in they become a distiller or get a
liquor manufacturer's license they make
750 cases in their first year
they are still eligible because of the
amount of their production
to take their products to farmers
markets if they wish
and uh operate there to sell it at
retail and offer samples things of that
nature
so they're they're similar in that they
deal with liquor manufacturers but
they're separate
um and they do mesh well they don't we
don't see any problem on our end
if both of these bills were to pass
okay it works for me
for the question yes representative i
have a question thank you mr chair i
have a question about um
the farmers markets um umbrella like the
department of agriculture that governs
the farmers markets are they
fine with this legislation do you know
well the uh the liquor manufacturer's
attendance at farmer's market it was the
third piece in what was previously
allowed for beverages
and then for wine
and
the establishment of allowing liquor
manufacturers to get there was just
rounding it out
so
we have nothing to do with the umbrella
of the farmer's market process other
than to tell the licensee
you're eligible to attend and
participate
under the rules established by the
farmers market so they
i'm not sure exactly what those are but
we would expect them to adhere to those
rules and whatever limitations were
imposed by the statute
okay representative van gaal thanks uh
i'm going to i'm also going to vote in
favor of this but i'm going to just
bring up something that i brought up in
the past several times because as we see
these bills kind of pulling together i
see the three tiers being
shoved elsewhere and i'm not necessarily
100 of a fan of the three tiers but if
we're going to have that system let's
have it let's not go beyond the
parameters of the system and and in
light of something that was said
yesterday relevant to another bill
um
we really need to to look to be sure
that we are ensuring equity among all
the all the uh different manufacturers
and distributors and everything else and
i think we're doing a patchwork
job of this right now i'm not blaming
you nor am i blaming the legislature but
i think in our in our
our haste if you will
to uh to bring things to life again in
new hampshire to get people outside to
get people enjoying themselves we may be
patching up pieces and not being careful
about how the whole lay of the land is
going to be presented and that's just my
soapbox for today and aiden nothing
against you guys or anybody i think our
purposes are valid and valuable but they
may not be bringing a result that we'll
be happy with five years down the road
well representative
i think alcohol laws are oftentimes uh
signified by
playing catch-up
one segment gets one thing and then the
other segments want to catch up and so
you may see
legislation following after legislation
where
there's a perception that one segment of
the industry has received an advantage
that the others don't have and then
there's the pursuit of
that type of parity
so
um
i would agree with you
that um
these laws are and whenever we see these
types of bills we always try to step
back and look at how they fit within the
system
the commission is never in the position
of trying to pick winners and losers but
we are trying to look at the system from
that
10 000 foot level to say what is the
impact here and we try to make sure that
we advise you what we see
before you decide what to do
i appreciate that and of course you know
we do
and as i said i think we have a mighty
purpose here i think we really do want
to
bring new hampshire back to life and and
to you know have those farmers markets
and have those delivery systems
and i appreciate that your oversight is
there but sometimes we do things that
don't necessarily
fit your picture shall we say no no
[Laughter]
thank you
i have hunt patusek
greeson van houten and bilo
all those in favor of the motion about
to pass raise your hand
[Music]
bye
okay moving on
uh now we're back to
business
um
prohibiting the sale of cosmetic
products tested on animals
i'd make a motion to otp
i don't want to do that you're not going
to recognize me i'm not going to
recognize you
uh
that's who's on this subcommittee now
business so which one is this is
business so i've got
ham who's not here right johnson
osborne
abel
herbert
and um van houghton is subbing subbing
for herbert
weston i'm subbing for
fargo and mclear
holy moly okay
uh yeah yeah just a second one two
three
so i have count four democrats is that
right
four and four three yes yeah no actually
looks like there's five i have bartlett
abel van houten and mcleer
okay yep you're all set four oh that's
four and four right so uh we'll have uh
what you want 100 patusek osborne
johnson and
terry
okay
uh so i'm more interested in
entertaining a motion of an expedient to
legislate
anybody like to make that motion
okay
we'll we'll have to discuss in just a
second
okay
and represent terry okay and represent
johnson you're recognized to speak to
your motion johnson
uh the reason for our two pass is when
we're making yes being deliberately oh i
ita sorry yeah
um
one it's making a
a law for a special class which we
shouldn't be doing it's against the law
if we're going to do this we're going to
do it we should be doing it for all
manufacturers in new hampshire
so across the board we either make it
for all or make it for none
okay representative bartlett um this is
making it for all cosmetic manufacturers
you know i mean our manufacturers period
the question you're making it for a
specific class of people
manufacturers of cosmetics that's that's
against constitutional law
you know naturally shaking here the
point being is is that is that
shouldn't we be saying that no testing
on animals
period regardless of the industry that's
doing the testing regardless of the
nature of the business
should if we're going to ban
animal testing
why wouldn't why are we only picking on
one industry which frankly
doesn't do it anyways
they don't do it anymore
that's what i'm saying is is that is
that you're if if they're not even doing
it we have no evidence that anybody's
actually testing on animals at all
why would you pick just that one
industry
rather than
i
i would venture to say that uh there are
a lot of industries that absolutely test
animals
so maybe we should come back with an
amendment that replaces this
and puts it for all industries is that
what you would prefer i'm i'm not
challenging i'm questioning right the
the point would be is that if it really
were if in terms of her point which is
um i i have a different point but that
her point is that
if you're if you're going to do this you
should not be picking out just cosmetic
industry you should be saying is we
don't want any testing on any animals
period in the state of new hampshire and
so my question is would you be bringing
an amendment to rewrite this to make
that if we can't get this itl yeah i'll
put an amendment in that says we can't
do this and then
so representative bartlett well i think
that um i mean one of the things you're
looking at is cosmetic industry you're
not looking at drugs
you're not looking at some you know
other kinds of industries that possibly
still need to be able to test
on animals um this is cosmetics
cosmetics
have a very different use than
life-saving drugs
for instance and i think that um this is
a
you know there's been in federal
legislation for years it's been bogged
down so now they've gone to the states
looking for the states to at least make
a very minimal
move
to prevent cruelty to animals
for an unnecessary reason
cosmetics are very different than
life-saving drugs
and i may i'm willing to make that
that concession and that admission
recognition
but i think that that we have
manufacturers that may still consider
and have historically tested their
products or ingredients in their
products on animals
and the feeling has been that it was
important to bring this forward they
spoke with a lot of stakeholders that
felt they could comply with this but we
don't know
if there are other um
plans out there for other companies that
may
not do this if the law was not in place
so i think it's really important and i
certainly will vote against
um
the itl because i think it's an
important bill no i i hear you missed it
so uh
representative terry yes
so just to reiterate uh what we said
yesterday particularly for those uh who
are in attendance uh this morning
i am unaware of any of the
representatives on this committee who
are
in favor
of uh
cruelty to animals or um
or a human being
so we're talking about this particular
bill
again today
and i'd like to thank mr ehrenberg
for
turning around
the questions and responding with uh
answers uh so quickly
i have a copy i don't know if anybody
else has a copy of this uh q a thank you
sir
um
he addresses specifically the question
and the concern that i raised yesterday
and so i'll just read the response for
the sake of those who may not have a
copy
the question was how will the law be
enforced and particularly to my question
has there been enforcement actions or
have there been enforcement actions
taken in other states or countries where
this is already
on the books as a law
the response that mr ehrenberg has
provided us is as follows quote there is
no economic incentive for companies to
violate this law as doing so would be a
pr nightmare
now i underscore in practice enforcement
would be complaint driven
someone needs to bring a complaint and
that would spur an investigation
california nevada and illinois laws that
have been in effect since january 1st
2020.
i interject at this point that's more
than two years ago
continuing and thus far we have not seen
any enforcement action that had to be
taken we are not aware of enforcement
actions taken in other countries close
quote
in other words we have laws on the books
in at least three other states
for over two years
and there have been no complaints filed
suggesting to me
that if we were to enact this bill we
are placing in law
something that really doesn't need to be
in law
because we have a record at this point
that in the states where the laws have
been on the books for over two years
there have been no complaints filed and
therefore no enforcement actions taken
therefore this suggests to me that this
is a bill that is unnecessary at this
time thank you mr chair
i could argue exactly the opposite of
that point the fact is that the bills
have been in effect and maybe in fact
there's no enforcement because people
are obeying the bill so i think that's a
the other side of the story and i don't
see that that's no reason not to have
that bill in force thank you
representative bartlett thank you mr
chair
so
i think it's really important that we
have
deterrent um it's difficult for in only
two years it's a very short period of
time for these bills to have been tested
um the other part of it is that there is
deterrent it's very it's not easy
to determine whether in
you know individual ingredients may have
been animal tested um that information
takes time to come out but i think that
the history
of this industry has not been good and
they've only been cleaning that up their
act by pressure
and a law prohibiting them from being
able to test on animals
um would would keep that pressure up
okay here's the reason why i'm opposed
to it and that is uh when i got into the
exemptions
and the exemptions
are unbelievable you can drive a truck
through them because theoretically
the idea that says well there's no
non-animal alternative method or
strategy recognized by any federal state
in the organization
to test safely the cosmetic agree or
non-functional constitution so
if
the
the idea that okay so the testing might
be okay
right that's what the whole list of here
there might be okay to do this testing
that's to me that defeats the whole
purpose of the legislation then when you
have the exemptions that are a whole
page long for a statue that's one
sentence
and i think it's very disingenuous to
say oh yeah we've we've banned that
when you have all these exemptions in
here
let alone the fact is why are you
picking on one industry well because it
was an industry that had history
but the history that i know today is
everybody's got on their product we
don't test
so it's already the marketplace and this
is where i come in
the marketplace has already addressed
this problem
if somebody were able to somebody see
something that had that animal testing
was involved believe you me that would
be on the front page of the newspaper
so why are we passing this
i mean if we went out and passed
legislation for every time the
marketplace solved the problem we said
well afterwards we want you know because
we love our puppies i mean this is this
a covet puppy problem here you know that
this is the time where we need to you
know love give love and care to our dogs
i mean come on now this is this this is
an unnecessary legislation
that the humane society has made a big
effort and want to push this but you
know that's that's a cause that they
care about i mean i understand but
heck
why aren't we worried about all the
other stuff i mean we actually did have
a bill in this committee
it was about antifreeze
and that antifreeze kills dogs
and the only reason the building pass
was that paul mccachren many recipes
uh offended because we had in it that uh
you couldn't uh uh the
the company that was manufacturing this
special chemical that was putting into
the antifreeze
wanted exempt wanted to be accepted from
lawsuits if it actually damaged your
engine
okay
this is i'm telling you we all care
about dogs we all want to take care of
our animals when she made the point to
me that well why why are we stopping
with just cosmetics and i said well
that's because that's the headline
that's the newspaper line that's what
everybody hears about but it's old news
you know and i just don't think we
should be cluttering our statutes with
things that the marketplace is actually
resolved
representative bilo
no we're in we're you know i mean we
don't take testimony so in subcommittee
this is something i think you can phrase
i bet you you can phrase what he once
would say why this is necessary but
it's you know
okay
representative griezmann
thank you mr chair
in uh in many of the cosmetic products
they have sunscreen
and some sunscreens are tested on
animals
or they may not be
but those that are
where would they fall is it a cosmetic
is it an ingredient in a cosmetic would
it be allowed because it has a history
of a use of ingredient but it's been
tested on animals you know how how do we
know because there are so many
there are so many everything from food
colorings to fire retardants to all
kinds of other products get tested on
animals for various different reasons
some of those may go into cosmetics but
they were tested on animals
so where does that all fit in this
statute if we limit it to just cosmetics
okay any more discussion on the motion
of any speed representative van gaal
yeah um
i mean i respect everybody's opinion
here and i know that we're not talking
about talking against animals that that
uh that we are doing that but we have
people from the industry people who have
seen from the inside out what's going on
and i respect their opinions and i
respect that they're saying that there
are still reasons why we need to have
this legislation
and so i will
um i will also vote against the itl for
that reason fair
enough
okay so
um i have hunt patusek osborne johnson
terry bartlett abel van houten and
mcaleer
let me just say in conclusion mr
chairman what's that with respect to uh
representative van halen's observation
at this point sure
i'm willing to reconsider this at a
point when i'm provided with documented
evidence
uh but i don't i don't see any and and
i'm not going to not vote today because
i'm waiting for evidence if i see
evidence next year or the year after if
i see that enforcement actions haven't
been brought in the states where the
laws have been adopted i'll take a
second look at this but i don't see this
right now as you don't thank you okay
all right
all those in favor of the motion and
explain to legislate please raise your
hand
and all those opposed
okay five to four
uh representative terry
johnson and terry
okay
next up uh 355 requiring online
marketplace to disclose certain
information to consumers
all right so this is
this is still
business right this is banking so that's
the same
able
immaculate
okay
who would like to make the motion
i'll make a motion to itl
okay representative johnson
secondly represent terry
moves any speed to legislate and
recognize to speak to emotion
i believe
doing some more research and looking it
over most of these big companies already
take responsibility for
the mark their market that they you know
people that sell on their website the
ones that
really need the oversight is like
facebook marketplace craigslist
things like that
these other people they can only control
how they
handle their third
um
third-party
sellers
so why do we need a law when they can
already do it and then protect the
consumers because if you know that
someone's going to protect you
based on their business model then
you're going to do more business with
them if they're not then you have a
choice not to it's consumer beware
and just follow
from
there
representative burroughs
i would just argue that
you know the threshold is five thousand
dollars of sales which isn't a lot uh in
sales so there are other marketplaces
other than walmart and
amazon
that can't afford to give that
protection when they're using these
third-party sellers so i think that
those companies those
consumers need protection there
not everybody buys from amazon or
walmart or cvs
representative bartlett
thank you
this is for new products only so i don't
think it usually applies to
facebook or craigslist
anyway
um i think we did have testimony that
amazon will stand behind products that
they purchase but you also know that
when you buy things from amazon
occasionally it'll say on the right on
the front of it this may be a final sale
so you don't have um an option
on that one um
but i think that this
gives them what do you mean by
this only applies to new items
this bill only applies to new items
is that that true brandon only new items
you think you were hiding back there
that i didn't see you why don't you come
up here until you sit on the come up
here and sit up sit here please
he's from aegis
he's not testifying he is a member of
the attorney general's office consumer
protection division that would be in
charge with enforcing this statute
he is not a lobbyist for a non-profit
go ahead
you turn your bike on
without the benefit of having the actual
bill in front of me my memory and
confidence is that it applies to new and
unused items
new and unused items okay in other words
did not it's not a used item that you
might find on ebay okay all right go
ahead confirm continue so i mean that's
what that's my point i think that there
and when we're the testimony that we
heard that we're talking about a a 500
billion dollar industry
of
stolen items
um
that that occur and they're they need a
place to be able to fence these if you
will
and this bill at least would give some
protection
um but fencing item means it would be
used
no
fencing doesn't mean they stole it in
its original packaging that's right okay
i mean
they can go into some of these jewelry
stores or the
the atvs that have been stolen the
chainsaws that have been stolen they're
they're bought they're right in the
cartons the snowmobiles that have been
stolen these are in the cartons that
they actually shipped it when they're
being stolen and to get to 500 billion
dollars
that's a heck of a lot of material that
they've got to figure out a way to sell
and this bill would at least give some
protection
um to the consumers that would be
purchasing
mr chair and the manufacturers
representative terry then represented
abel
so uh rhetorically speaking uh was i not
here yesterday and here's the actual
question
did i not hear
that with respect to
the question of final sale
and the concern about final sale
that we heard
that where there is fraud
and deception
that those
actions come under existing law so that
there really is no such thing as a final
sale when there is fraud and deception
could we just have that reiterated been
clarified if need be please
could you clarify what you mean by
finding i i i understand the second part
of the question i don't understand the
final sale component of it what are you
referring to i believe that we have
discussed
together our shared knowledge
that sometimes when
an amazon or i don't believe walmart but
amazon and i've never seen on amazon but
let's say hypothetically amazon will
indicate that that whatever that the
sale
uh that they are
the product that's being offered on
their platform by a third-party seller
that product is uh a final sale
so it's unreturnable and you can't get
your money back
but suppose there's fraud and deception
on the part of the third party seller
what the concern that i'm hearing is is
that
final sale means final sale even if
there's fraud and deception what i
thought i heard yesterday is if you can
prove fraud and deception then final
sale is not final sale so there is in
fact protection under existing consumer
protection law
is that correct or something close to it
i think something close to it so close
enough in that instance and this was my
testimony from yesterday
if you have a seller regardless of
whether it's the marketplace or it's a
third-party seller who's selling on the
marketplace that are making any sort of
false or deceptive representations about
the product that they're selling it's
not an issue of whether it's all sales
are final you know because the consumer
arguably would not have engaged in the
sale to begin with but for the deceptive
statement so nobody can hide behind a
you know well all sales are final if
they've made deceptive statements and
yes that is i believe covered by
existing unfair and deceptive acts or
practices prohibition under rsa 358a
does the chair want you to stay here or
yes just stay right there thank
you
representative abel
yes thank you uh thank you for your help
as well um
seems to me that
uh that this bill
does a number of things
and to
to vote
itl
would be to take a step that is
anti-consumer because it hurts the
consumer's ability to get to
to deal with this kind of a problem
uh
from the government point of view from
the
attorney general's office that would
need to enforce
would need to enforce it and would need
to do
investigations it makes it much much
harder
to identify
the party that has
has defrauded someone
and thirdly i think it's it's a this is
this is to vote for an anti-business
position
because the businesses
that are acting as the platform
um
are taking a lot of this this is a big
loss for them a big expense for them to
deal with
these kinds of problems they're in favor
of this bill
and so i'm surprised actually that
my colleagues from the other party are
taking a position that will be
interpreted as both
uh both
anti-consumer and anti-business and
that's the way i see it so i i'm going
to vote against the itl
representative bartlett
we also had testimony from the new
hampshire police association that
supports the bill strongly so i think
that that's also um
an important endorsement
representative greeson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
sitting in the hot seat i appreciate
that happy too
would this legislation
cover
facebook marketplace craigslist
ebay and those types of
of platforms that allow sales
understanding it would we we definitely
understand it would cover an amazon and
a walmart
but what about the
the uh
the facebook marketplace and things like
that um
where
more than likely the stolen items from
the smash and grabs are going to find
themselves listed because of amazon has
quite the scrutiny to be on their
marketplace
so i don't know that
it
there's no yes and there's no no i think
that depending on whether this covers an
online marketplace that allows
third-party sellers who are dealing new
and unused merchandise so to the extent
that i know you know craigslist i don't
spend a ton of time on craigslist but
the times that i've been on it a lot of
the stuff that's being offered are you
know private parties selling their used
items their personal items that they're
trying to get rid of so it would not
apply to those sales
um if there are and i don't know if
there are
third-party sellers on craigslist whose
business is selling new and unused
merchandise through craigslist
potentially it could i don't think
that's craigslist's business model i i
have to admit i'm very unfamiliar with
facebook marketplace i know that
there
are a high volume of similar private
sales of used merchandise on facebook
marketplace i'm unaware of whether they
have like designated high volume
third-party sellers like amazon and like
walmart does um but if they did that
we're dealing in new and unused
merchandise then i believe it would
apply to them as well
representative
i just have a question is
facebook considered a marketplace
is a consumer feature but
i won't i don't trust facebook and you
know i don't go anywhere near it myself
so i think we're gonna get this
discussion back to the to the bigger
picture these are the big
operators that are trying to move
big thefts
and that's what this is this is to
protect
so i i guess enforcement to be able to
have something with teeth in it
but we haven't seen i don't
we don't have an anecdotal story of
someone of this really actually
occurring in new hampshire well yeah we
know about the smashing grass
we've had some big thefts here that are
done with organized crime
um and they've got to find a place to
sell their stuff when they're taking out
truckloads of atvs and chainsaws and
these are all in the original packaging
they come in they smash it they
um have picked it up it's gone twice in
manchester one of the atv
we don't we don't have laws against
thievery and organized crime to begin
with
how they're getting rid of their their
products
okay representative police represent
that hound let me go ahead thank you um
i think we're losing sight of another
facet of this and that is that
we're closing a door of criminals before
the fact we don't have to
catch them after the fact and find them
i mean as far as i know and i've not
lived a criminal life but as far as i
know anonymity is the greatest strength
of a criminal if i'm going to steal her
phone right now i want to do it a non
most not
without being seen without having my
identity compromised and so i think that
that's another facet of this as well
because we don't only have to worry
about criminals after the fact
why open doors for them to have that
criminality now especially in such large
volume as what we're talking about thank
you
okay
represent back later oh thank you i just
remember that this not only protects the
consumer but it also protects the
manufacturer and believe me the
manufacturer is very interested in
finding out you know who's doing these
break-ins and taking their stuff so i
think we we fail to uh to recognize that
as well thank you
okay
representative griezmann thank you mr
chair
uh how would we go about
uh protecting a consumer when the third
party
is in guangzhou china
because you buy things on amazon
marketplace
and the seller it they already list
where they're located
and
your option is guangxiu china for five
bucks or hoboken new jersey for 27
which one you're going to buy from
and you don't have 27 but you've got
five so you buy from guangzhou and now
you're toast how
how are we going to protect people when
that third-party seller is overseas
representative mclaren thank you
i think the answer to that question is
that once we find out that that seller
is from uh china and somebody's been
taken then these the amazons the
walmart's they're going to shut them
down
so we may have to to wait until a crime
has been committed but i think this will
this law will prevent
those people from we already but they're
already doing this now i mean i
suggested yesterday that i've i've had
issues in the past with a third party
seller i've contacted amazon amazon has
refunded me the money immediately and
said that they were going to undertake
an investigation of the third party
seller because it's bad business for
amazon to continue to have a third party
seller selling stuff on amazon if these
these uh issues continue to present
themselves that reflects badly on the
third-party seller they go right after
them and terminate them and boom no more
on amazon that that's the experience
that's what's happening
i mean that's real life
representative
thank you sir uh
basic question
would this feel when it becomes law if
it becomes law enable
disable or be neutral for your position
i guess i need you to
elaborate a little bit on that question
yeah okay my my position
as chief of the consumer protection
bureau yes uh
so in what we use you asked enable
disable or be neutral
in what regard
my question i think it would enable him
to be able to make a phone call and try
to make the consumer hold yeah that
would certainly enable him to do that
this make your job easier
is basically enabling
in my in my view
so i i don't know if it's as simple as
answering that question i don't know
that i can answer that exact question um
will it make it
it would make it easier to identify
high volume third-party sellers if the
online marketplaces are complying with
this law as adopted and compiling
verifying and providing
contact identifying information for
third high volume third party sellers
to consumers or to the attorney
general's office upon request
thank you
okay
any more discussion on the motion of any
speeding to legislate
see none
all those in favor of the motion please
raise your hand
you're not gonna vote for itl
okay what motion would you rather have
okay
are you okay with that
sure we can get to vote okay uh all the
the itl motion failed but if you'd like
to have a motion we would get cert
i can't okay
i didn't think i was going to pick up a
vote on your side so
okay all those in favor raise your hand
of no right now we're itl
okay all those in favor of itl
one two three
all those opposed
one two three four five okay
six sorry
three to six okay
all right representative terry motion to
interim study
moves representation secondly
representative osborne
uh moves to interim study
any discussion on the interim study
motion
yes representative yes i'd like to know
what uh
kind of interim study would be done
would be conducted
well i would be hoping to hear from the
ag's office if a complaint like this
comes through
that that i would like to know if if you
get any you know the calls i know at
some point time you guys were supposed
to tracking all your complaints all the
different complaints that come into the
consumer protection line
we track all of our i review all the
complaints that come in and we track
them in our database so i'm hoping to
come
next september when we do an interim
study meeting
that you'll be able to bring in how many
complaints have been
made
on on
that would have been affected by this
legislation obviously you don't know
whether they're high volume or not but
i'd be very interested to hear about
complaints about
um any uh uh mark you know in internet
marketplaces
what the nature of the complaints that
you're that you're hearing is that
possible
what i could
almost certainly do
if i were to receive a request to
provide information
to the study i could compile
complaints that we receive in a certain
date range against um
the known high volume third-party
sellers amazon walmart ebay
and in a redacted capacity removing any
identifying information from the
consumers speak generally about the
nature of what the complaints looked
like that would be awesome yes so mr
chair just to be clear
the complaints that you receive against
the amazons and walmarts
with and with the following question
answered did amazon
have you have you contacted amazon in
walmart
etc and they have refused to resolve or
they have unsatisfactorily resolved
your complaint
what i want to what i want to get at
here is that we don't have people that
are contacting your office
about an issue with the third high
volume third party seller that haven't
attempted initially to resolve the issue
through
the through amazon walmart et cetera
clear
could you ask a more direct i think he's
basically saying
when you get a call you will follow up
with the person to find out whether
they've actually attempted to call
amazon to assure you know that that the
problem that that they're calling you
now because they did not get a uh uh a
respectful response from amazon or
walmart or whatever the the market the
the internet provider
did not give a response and that's why
they're calling you
so our response to complaints depends
completely and the facts of the specific
complaint we do not have a
one-size-fits-all policy where we will
or won't accept a complaint if the
consumer has or hasn't done various
things we try to look at the facts of
every complaint and make the right
decision based on what information the
consumer is providing
i don't know that i can say generally
every time a consumer files a complaint
against a
third-party seller that we would insist
or verify that they had contacted amazon
or another market but you would you
would note if the customer mentions
whether they have attempted to
notify them what we're trying to get out
here is we would like you to
discriminate between those complainants
who have not contacted
amazon walmart
and those who have
and are reporting to you
that they're dissatisfied with what the
amazons and walmarts have done
all right what i would suggest is at the
point in time where the committee would
like
the attorney general's office through me
to come and provide information to send
a very specific request for the type of
information that you're looking for and
that would put us in a position to
evaluate the request and come prepared
to answer those exact questions if
that's something the attorney general
authorizes which i i suspect that he
would so if we interim study what you're
saying is you you'd like the directive
you collect clear directions
when we're scheduling it and he'll then
generate the list put in writing what we
said today okay thank you well the the
specific questions that you would like
the office to be prepared to answer so
that we can assess a whether we can
answer them and b make sure that we're
providing accurate answers based on you
know the information we review we
appreciate that yep all right
representative bartlett thank you
um i'm just wondering if representative
osborne um
would speak to his motion
what it is that you're looking for
because i see you don't have the bill in
front of you and i know you weren't
there for
oh everything's on there okay um
anything that my colleagues were saying
earlier on any normal day i would be on
board
he does do you have to turn your mic on
sorry i'd rather not repeat all that but
um
yes this uh bill is important to some uh
people and uh we'd like to make sure
that we investigate uh more fully and
come back to it next year
okay
yeah
it was it was discussed i wrote a note
here to myself uh from yesterday that
the retail association does not see
any need to make any modification to
this bill
despite personal testimony
suggesting some mechanism
and what i don't remember is what that
mechanism is supposed to be
and that's there was some other
discussion going on in there but some
kind of a mechanism if anybody recalls
that from testimony yesterday so maybe
this interim study might be able to
determine what that mechanism might be
the language that i wrote down mr
chairman uh needful of a mechanism
suggesting a need for a mechanism to
identify tps and have that displayed to
the consumer that's what that's what
the attorney general brings recommended
okay
so motion clear now it's uh interim
study all those in favor of interim
studies raise your hand one two three
four five all those opposed
one two three four okay
all right
onward and upward
thank you
thank you very much brandon for coming
in
senate bill 324 uh relative to
resolution disputes for condominium unit
owners homeowners association unit
owners and tenant owned manufactured
housing parks
um
i will i will make the motion of
inexpedient to legislate
and anybody want to second my motion
okay
um
uh
i think
representative said it you know this is
this bill is not ready for prime time
yes representative van gaal
thank you um and i agree i will vote for
the ito i'm just hoping to clarify i
think there was a little bit of
confusion when the bill was
was uh discussed yesterday
the original bill is very different from
the bill that we're looking at right now
the bill that we're looking right at
right now just gives the
the owner whether it be a condo or
another similar kind of building
to go back to the board and bring that
complaint to the same person and that
just seems counterintuitive so if i have
an issue with you because you have fined
me for something i can get a hearing
with you but i don't see that that's
going to be very helpful the mechanism
of going to court has always been
available and so um with great respect
and and
and and and i certainly feel for the
people who've come i understand their
concerns and their needs this is not the
mechanism to make them whole in the way
that they want to be made whole and so i
will reluctantly vote itl not because my
heart is not with them but because this
is not the right way to fix it for them
okay
all right is the motion clear
all those in
favor okay yeah the bush committee is
here
uh this is business so
yeah
and so osborne has left the house
okay
bartlett
abel
and howard
okay hunt patusek greeson johnson terry
bartlett abel and van houten
and oh michael because you're way down
at the bottom that's how i keep missing
you okay sorry
sorry chris
okay all those in favor of any speed to
legislate please raise your hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten
concept
okay
i don't know how we get to 10 but
i don't know
right
yes i must have counted one
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
okay nine
nothing okay
i think
representative weston scooted me up on
that one
you raised your hand
okay
all right we'll try again on the next
one
okay
all right 286 establishing the
associated health plan pilot program
this is health insurance
who would like to make the itl motion
representative
i'd like to move this bill idea okay
i'll second now
okay
and
an excuse to legislate okay and you
recognize to speak to your motion
um
i'm moving itl because um
the evidence was that this bill that
will not result in any cost savings for
for um for these groups and um that
there may be adverse selection in terms
of people who choose to be in these
groups would be young and healthy and it
also looks like they're not going to be
getting more than they're getting right
now through these association plans
and then we have a similar statute
already on the books that maybe the
number's a little different but it's
already exists
thank you mr chair i support the itl
motion
[Music]
anything that we try to do
to try to lower costs is going to get
preempted by the federal government
because anything that would actually
lower costs is going to be forbidden
you you well if you were trying to pull
out mandates
well it it's if you try to get a group
of people who are
of a similar demographic and healthy you
can't take them out of the general pool
because then that would raise the rates
of those who would be of a demographic
that would generally be under health if
it was a guaranteed issue right and so
uh in any kind of pi and not only that
but a pilot program that doesn't last
long enough to actually see results
uh
in in two years
they would call it a success because
there were no claims in the third year
everybody is filing claims and they
don't have insurance now so how do you
get them back to a plan that they had
beforehand if there was any failure
there's no mechanism to and i mean
there's already a law that would require
them to be covered but how do we know
that going back to a previous plan
wouldn't end costing them more
right
so
okay
all right any more discussion on the
motion of any speed to legislate seeing
none all those in favor please raise
your hand one two three four
five six seven eight
seven
all right
well this is
you're not you're
this is insurance
okay
uh
all right amen
okay
seven to one okay
and all those opposed to the motion
okay where was his name
you vote i have seven to one here
so so we have an even number
i i
i'm not worrying about it
we don't need a recount because
right okay because it wasn't close
okay
senate bill
287 uh relative to balanced billing for
certain health care services
um glad to make the motion okay
representative bartlett i'd like to make
a motion of interim study on this one
you want to in it i mean the interim
studying please okay
you can interrupt it
all right representative bartlett second
by representative hunt moves uh interim
study on senate bill 287
and representative bartlett it's
recognized to speak to her motion um i
just think that there's some um issues
with this one i think we've got um
pending court case regarding the federal
language on it um i think that having it
amended back and forth between who
should be the referee is not a a good
it's not time to do that i think we
should wait
until um
we figure out what's going to happen
with the language
on the feds so this can come back
another term
okay
all right so this one
yes okay
greason
johnson
this is no this is a health insurance
bill
balanced billing
and
[Music]
uh
bartlett
and
burroughs
mcaleer
you've got hunt greece and terry and
emin
yeah but evidently keith thinks he's on
health insurance is this we don't
differentiate between health insurance
and insurance
insurance yeah i think that's what i
said
right insurance is insurance right so
i'm on the that's what i'm saying i got
you yeah at one point we used to buy
bifurcate them but
this year we didn't because they were
there everything no i have anyone on
insurance okay
all right all those in favor of the
interim study motion please raise your
hand
six seven eight
eight to nothing
right
all right here we go perfect
and last but not least
relative direct-to-consumer shipment of
alcohol of to new hampshire residents
senate bill 340.
okay
okay so i i have a particular problem
with this is because i agreed to the 27
some 25 years ago what's the motion
so i i'm i'm just saying that
i have i'm i'm somewhat conflicted on
this bill
did you do we have a motion to discuss
we don't we don't have a motion listen
you want to make a motion
well i was i was hoping somebody make a
motion because i'd like to hear from mr
moore
okay
who's okay
okay yeah represent below
okay she moves out to pass
and
excuse me here we go
okay so let me see who i've got here all
right so i have
two sec
and we have greason
patusek will second the motion
okay
uh so who else is on liquor now
manhattan of course yep
and
okay but
okay so right now
all right so right now i have hun
patoosa greason and van hounten and bilo
that work
okay
all right so representative below and
second by representing patusek moves out
to pass
you want to speak to your motion please
i support it because it makes a lot of
sense i i don't think you can compare it
to you know to
distill products or
wine because especially distilled
because
beer has a lot less you know alcohol um
volume to it so i agree i listened to
the testimony from
um from our liquor commissioner and um
he did not testify on this bill well
i've talked to him about it
you said commissioner so there's no
commissioner in the room right right
there with a commission commission
right um
okay
did we not hear yesterday that with
respect to the
magic number 27 and the new magic number
of 50
that no seller is even beginning to
approach 27.
one i believe there was one that was
that asked oh there was just one and
the one is not a member of the
association
i think you're right so that this would
in effect
this is tantamount to a special interest
bill yeah you're right for one and and
i'm uncomfortable with that yes i think
you remember it correctly uh thank you
ma'am
i'll remember this is a highlight moment
for me thank you
okay
all right so motion is i t l represent
julio second by representative batusex
moves in expedition to the legislature
did we not get a second on out to pass
is that why we're i we were did we vote
it down did we do that we can
emotion can be oh i'm sorry motion can
be withdrawn i was thinking at the time
and that was yep
so i might be yelling
so i i would say i have mixed emotions
about this bill obviously
notwithstanding this is uh my pride and
joy the statute um
first of all i am incredulous
that anybody would want to
take beer as a direct shipment
and pay the eight percent
john hunt memorial tax
why why would anybody want to pay that i
just can't imagine however given this
particular because you know this was
during the
shutdown wherever he was at home this
person obviously decided that that there
were people were out there wanting to do
it but this this number is about an
individual consumer so again
i'm incredulous and anybody would
actually take advantage of this
of moving this number up and uh on top
of that that's the number i agreed to
way back when so i i i'd like to be
consistent let's say and i see no
compelling real reason to change the
number so i uh support the unexpected to
legislate motion representative van
houden
thank you i don't disagree with any
anything that you've said
um but i go back to my testimony or to
my statements earlier about equity and
fairness and and looking at the
three-tier system as something that
either needs to be protected or
dismantled or whatever and that i think
we have um as we've said before we've
made movements for different for liquor
for instance or for beer for instance
and
catching up and allowing other other
parts of the industry to uh also have
those movements in their favor so
in heart and soul no i don't agree with
this but in terms of my belief that we
need to be fair all the way around um i
do believe in it
okay
um
since it's not 12 i will respond
even before i
uh liquor started coming to commerce
when it used to be in regulated revenues
uh
so it's long before anybody in this room
maybe aiden was around
when they
created uh brew pubs
were you around for brew pubs
okay
and i am sure at the time somebody
pointed out that brew pubs are the
uh the trampling i mean this is not just
stomping this is trampling destroying
kicking
of the three-tier system
because in that case it violated every
element of the three-tier
we have a manufacturer who's who's
retailing who's selling uh and and
distributing uh every you know so at
that point we would you could
call into question whether
how whether we're really committed to
the three-tier
system the three-tier was a concept
that we created obviously at the end of
the prohibition
and
who knows which is the real three-tier
when the state of new hampshire chose to
get into the liquor business
when you think the three-tier really
meant was that you would have
distributors
and you and you would have uh retailers
which and come to still we don't even
we don't have that
except for one licensee two licensees
that were have a special privilege of or
able to sell but
otherwise i i i would never i would
never hang my hat on defending or
you know premising around the three-tier
other than maybe that's the concept we
were we were framework we were working
from
because as far as i'm concerned the
three-tier system
absolutely went out the window you know
even with my direct shipping bill you
know there was no three-tier involved
and i think that's very much the case
and i know that there has been a lot of
examination of the liquor commission and
and the runnings of the of the liquor
commission i it is just my hope that we
will settle on something that's fair and
equitable and that suits the state of
new hampshire and continues to bring the
types of income
safely into our state because as you
know many of the stances that i take on
liquor have to do with vaping and
underage drinking and things of that
sort so the word safely is is an operant
word for me here too
so
right now i'm looking at a fairness
issue
and um
either we have something and we don't
have something and again
in the scheme of things this is not the
biggest bill that we deal with
uh and so i will be voting against the
what's the what's the motion otp emotion
right now it's
inexpl with my preference being otp
really okay
all right
is the motion clear
all those in favor of supporting itl
please raise your hands
one two three four
and those opposed
what order one
i'm sorry i didn't see you jane
yes so you were one of the five okay
right one two three four one
five so who who voted it shouldn't have
been recent you're not on this terry
what liquor yeah at this moment i didn't
i'm not i'm not wearing that uniform
right not today okay all right four to
one four to one okay
okay well all right
i think that does everything
everybody
yeah
and we'll see you all next wednesday
so uh be aware that if i find something
that we need a subcommittee on i'll
schedule it for
for next wednesday but otherwise
consumer assume we're all in the clear
um
all right thank you guys are you sure
thank you
well when i talked about the half day
and there's a woman that said wonderful
woman like she was my second mother
um